remember that you can join the
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
a few posts i spotted this morning i
want to bring to your attention because
i think they're interesting
our user nash t asks what's going on
with the matt gates investigation has it
all been swept under the rug
writing i'm horrified that so much has
come out about gates and yet he's still
going about life business as usual i
understand high profile cases take time
but what exactly is the timeline here
this is exactly why
when back in the summer
all of the news articles were saying
investigation arrest may be imminent and
gates's partner in crime was confessing
and pointing the finger at gates this is
why i was saying i don't know that gates
gets indicted i don't know that gates
gets charged i don't know that gates
gets arrested
and why there was no particular reason
other than oftentimes these guys just
avoid consequences one way or the other
now we don't know the status of the
investigation i'm hopeful that it will
at some point uh lead to charges if that
is what is determined should happen on
the basis of the investigation but this
is exactly why i said let's take it a
step at a time uh i'm wondering just as
much as you are what is going on with
matt gates another post is about the
reduced price of at home covid testing
remember last week joe biden announced
that the covid at home coveted tests
would be offered at cost
walmart has lowered the cost
to 14
for a two pack and as user bae photo
points out
if this is at cost
it will be too expensive for many and
that i think that that's absolutely
right i've said before
i think that at five dollars a test it
starts to become
i don't know about it appealing but
doable for people who say
might be having
people over for an indoor event and they
say hey you know what let's be extra
safe let's test everybody
four dollars a test
i do think that seven dollars a test is
probably still too high
and i don't know how much at home
testing we're going to get voluntarily
at that price
maybe the prices will continue to come
down but i think around the four dollar
a test mark is
what would make sense to me so far it
seems like it's not going to go below
seven at least in the immediate another
user asked does david think teachers are
the problem with the education system in
the us
writing does anyone else get the
impression david puts blame on teachers
and schools for some of the problems of
today's society i'm sure he doesn't
intend to but at times it sounds like
david is trashing education and teachers
he will say things like the us education
system is failing or schools don't teach
critical thinking anymore
well that's true
an uneducated listener might think david
is advocating for privatized education
or incentivized teacher pay
both of which have been studied
extensively and are terrible for schools
teachers and students
uh no i i want to be so
that that is not what i am saying when i
say we have a failing educational system
um i am talking about a combination of
misplaced priorities as a result of
often politicized school boards
that have been taken over by
right-wingers who don't want critical
think critical thinking taught or
philosophy or epistemology etc so so
that's often
partisan school boards
and it's a funding issue where we always
have money for you know you know the
stuff right you know the drill we always
have money for bombs we always have
money for war but when it's education we
always have to be fighting for and
justifying every dollar so i'm not
blaming teachers i think 90 something
percent of teachers are doing the best
they can with the resources they have
and the curricula that they are in many
school districts
obligated to teach to and teach from i
am not blaming teachers i am not blaming
teachers glad for the opportunity to
clarify
join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit